What do you do if a kid is in danger?
Sometimes shouting at them is enough.
But what if the kid is REALLY in danger?
As in, just within pouncing distance
of a very hungry tiger danger?
You might keep the kid quiet, wait for the coast to clear,
and then when it’s safe, explain the danger.
That might seem like the obvious answer,
but in nature, very few animals are
capable of holding it all in.
This ability to WAIT-- and communicate information
after an event has passed -- or about an event
that will happen in the future --
is called “displaced reference.”
Humans do it.
Honeybees do it.
And now, it turns out that orangutans do it, too.
Researchers conducted an experiment
with seven female orangutans in the
Ketambe jungle of northeast Sumatra.
They pretended to be predators by draping
themselves with giant sheets and crawling
along the forest floor.
One sheet was covered in a tiger-stripe pattern,
one had a pattern of abstract colors,
one was white with multi-colored spots,
and the last was a plain white sheet.
Once the “predator” was spotted by an orangutan,
the researcher would stop for two minutes
before moving out of sight.
Surprisingly, the orangutans would wait several
minutes before letting out a warning call.
They did this in 12 of the 24 trials,
with an average delay of seven minutes.
So why the wait?
Sumatran orangutans have the longest
child-rearing period of any primate -- infant orangutans
stay with their mothers for up to 9 years,
which allows them to develop
critical forest survival skills.
Letting out a warning call at the first sight of a predator
is just too dangerous, because it might alert
the predator to their presence.
But, at the same time,
the parent needs to teach the infant to
recognize these situations in the future.
So the mothers wait --
long enough that the danger has passed,
but short enough that the
infant can still learn from the encounter.
Researchers say this clearly demonstrates
the ability to use displaced reference in
a non-human primate --
something never seen before in the wild.
And that suggests another way that orangutans,
one of our closest-living relatives
and a prolific communicator,
may be a model for how language evolved in people.
Who knows?
If we gave orangutans a million years,
they just might have something to say.